The answer to this question might surprise you.
It's not the variant with the three letters that
are deleted, but the one with the single
letter deletion. And the reason is incredibly interesting. Because
the codon reading frame shifted. Think about it
for a second. In this first scenario here, you're
the ribosome, and you're reading the sequence, right. So
you'd read the codon GTC C, T, C, G,
T, oh my gosh, whadda we do? We're missing
one. What's going to happen, is it's going to read the very
next letter, and that's going to be associated with the
codon GTG. Well, notice GTG is the exact same as
what it was before. And now we go to
ACC. And what essentially happened, is GTGAC, we skipped over
this whole GTG to this ACC and every thing
from here on out is pretty much the same thing.
So, it's bad, right we lost three letters, but
in the end we only lost one whole amino acid;
where as down here, if we're at the ribosome, we
get the first codon, the second codon and then we
get here, skip one, got to a G well
we're still the same GTG But now we're going to keep
moving to the next three, and we get TGA, CCC,
CTT, G, and you'll notice that these codons are not
the same as these codons up here. They're very different. And on top of it, this
codon here, TGA, what does that code for? It codes for a big ol' STOP codon.
So this mutation here, we only deleted one
letter, but it caused a frame shift. And
then, we introduced an early stop code on.
This is going to drastically change the protein sequence,
compared to this mutation, which at this deletion
here Even though the deletion was three letters
and this one was only one letter, this
variation is far more significant in the resulting protein.